[Music]
as you deploy workloads in Google cloud
you need centralized visibility into the
security posture and status of your
environment you need a way to surface
vulnerabilities and malicious activity
with clear ways to take action against
them security command center is a
built-in security management tool for
Google cloud platform that helps you
prevent detect and remediate
vulnerabilities and threats you can
identify misconfigured virtual machines
containers network storage and Identity
and Access Management policies as well
as web application vulnerabilities and
act on them before they damage your
business with security command center
you can perform several security related
actions from a single centralized
dashboard let's get started by
completing three steps step 1 set up
cloud iam permissions to get started you
need to ensure you have the correct
permissions set up in cloud iam these
roles can be enabled from the GCP
console I am an admin page to view the
security command center you must have
the security center admin viewer role to
make changes you must have an
appropriate editor role like security
center admin editor to set up security
command center for the first time for
your organization you will need five
roles organization admin Security Center
admin Security Center settings admin
security admin and service account
creator step 2 choose services head to
the console in the left hand panel
navigate to security and then click
security command center on the
organization drop-down list select your
organization note if this is the first
time your organization is using security
command center you will be directed
through a signup flow where you will
choose your services for organizations
that have already completed the signup
flow you may review and refine your
services from the UI to do so click on
add security sources to review and
enable the services that security
command center will use to show you the
security state of your resources our
built in services are security health
analytics which can identify
misconfigured virtual machines
containers network storage and Identity
and Access Management policies the
built-in capabilities in the standards
here and
scans for high-severity
misconfigurations such as open storage
buckets when using security health
analytics in the premium tier you get
scans for broader security
misconfigurations such as API keys
needing to be rotated in addition you
get compliance monitoring and security
posture management against PCI DSS CIS
GC p10 NIST 853 and ISO 27001
recommendations among other security
best practices for premium users there
are additional services available web
security scanner managed scan
capabilities which automatically detect
new public facing web applications
deployed on Google cloud and can detect
vulnerabilities in those applications
including those from categories in the
wasp
top 10 such as cross-site scripting use
of clear text passwords and outdated
libraries event threat detection which
uses log data from inside your systems
and watches your organization's cloud
login stream to detect threats like
brute force SSH cloud AM abuse malware
and data exfiltration container threat
detection which can detect some of the
most common threats seen in container
raised workloads running on gke such as
adversaries dialing home with reverse
shells or the execution of binaries and
libraries that did not come from your
secure build pipeline you can also
integrate with other services to have
their findings surfaced and security
command center cloud armor which is a
customizable service for protecting
applications from DDoS or web attacks
cloud armor since any allowed traffic
spike and increasing deny ratio findings
to security command center data loss
prevention which shows storage buckets
that contain sensitive and regulated
data integrates and services its
findings into security command center
and partner solutions from many partners
such as chef automate which can be
integrated into security command center
and enabled here you can enable or
disable a service by clicking the toggle
next to the service name the services
will be enabled at the organization
level optionally you can enable or
disable your services for individual
resources by navigating to the resources
tab click the drop-down list in the
service column to select service
enablement on a resource now security
command center is ready to help you
prevent detect and respond to threats
this leads up to step number
three view your dashboards security
command center gives you a lot of
flexibility to review the security state
of your resources explorer contains a
directory of the dashboards displays and
services available to you on the threats
dashboard you can review potentially
harmful events in your organization's
resources these events are summarized by
severity category and resource or
project the threats dashboard displays
results for the time period you specify
in the drop-down list click through
these items to see more detail on the
specific findings the vulnerabilities
dashboard displays security health
analytics findings and recommendations
the findings can be filtered to one or
more projects and also by other
characteristics such as category
severity and or benchmarks the
recommendations column provides a
summary of how to remediate the finding
more details on the finding can be
viewed by clicking through the
compliance dashboard uses security
health analytics and web security
scanner detectors to monitor for
violations against common compliance
controls which are part of various
industry regimes including CIS and PCI
well not a replacement for a compliance
audit it can be used to help you
maintain your continuous compliance and
catch violations early you can filter by
project and view or export reports of
specific findings by compliance regime
if you'd like to export security command
center data including assets and
findings you can find the export button
on the assets or finding tabs on the
dashboard you can also have a vent
threat detection and container threat
detection findings automatically log to
cloud logging to enable navigate to
settings and click on the syncs tab
where you can turn on this service
congratulations that's it your setup to
start using security command center
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you
[Music]